[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to the
Quick Start Tutorial
for Managed Kubernetes.
Today, we're going to deploy
a containerized application.
First, we'll need to enable
the Kubernetes Engine
API on our project.
In the navigation menu,
click on API and Services,
and then click Enable
APIs and Services.
Here, search for
Kubernetes Engine
and select it from the results.
On the Kubernetes
Engine API page,
click Enable to enable
it on the project.
Next, let's activate the
Cloud Shell in our console
where we'll run our commands.
Once we're here, we can
specify the default zone
that we want the G Cloud
and kubectl commands to use.
Type gcloud config set compute
zone followed by a zone.
For this demonstration,
let's use us-east1.
With our default zone set, let's
create a Kubernetes cluster.
A cluster consists of at
least one cluster master
and multiple worker
machines called nodes.
These nodes are
Compute Engine VMs that
run the Kubernetes processes.
An application is deployed to a
cluster and runs on its nodes.
Enter the command gcloud
container clusters create
and a cluster name.
Once our cluster
is created, we'll
need authentication credentials
to interact with it.
We'll get that with
gcloud container clusters
get credentials followed
by the cluster name.
The get credentials subcommand
will configure Q cuddle,
the command line interface
for running commands
against Kubernetes clusters to
use a cluster we just created
in any subsequent commands.
Now, it's time to deploy a
containerized application
to our cluster.
Type kubectl, create deployment,
and a name for deployment.
Let's go with hello server.
We've provided a sample web
application called Hello App.
We can specify its Google
Container Registry URL
with the dash dash image tag.
Our application is
deployed, but if we
want to see what it
looks like, we'll
need to expose it
to the internet
by creating a
Kubernetes service.
Type kubectl exposed deployment
followed by our deployment
name, hello server.
We'll specify a type,
load balancer, a port, 80,
and a target port, 8080.
This means that the load
balancer will initialize
the public port 80 to the
internet and route traffic
to port 8080 of the application.
After a few minutes, the load
balancer should be all set up
and have an assigned
external IP address.
Kubectl get service followed
by our deployment name
will show us the
IP address we'll
use to access our application.
Enter that IP address
in a new tab or window,
and there you have it.
We've just deployed a
containerized web application
to Kubernetes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]